let's get into hatred mail we've got a
very special hatred mail this week but
first what is hatred mail anyway we're
so all right it's wrong hatred mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay so as you probably know the
voice you hear during hatred mail is not
the actual voice of the hatred but it is
a professional deep voice movie
announcer guy volunteers to do the
hatred mail voiceovers we are not
identifying him at his request and he
felt that this week's hatred mail really
lent itself towards a slightly different
accent in its interpretation and that is
why this is a very very special hatred
mail this week take a listen to this I
think you'll like it I love how much of
a Jew you are you lie about Trump you're
a soul you jerk you're a far left is who
hates Trump Trump's better than the
northern terrorist Abraham Lincoln and
socialist communist cook at the yar he
brought down debt by 10 Billy you dick
in the first month the liberal media is
purposely trying to discard Trump just
to gain power just please watch Project
Veritas you lefty Putin and Trump is
better than your butt buddies Obama
Merkel who endlessly promote
multiculturalism or in scientific talk
white genocide promoted by godless
communist [ __ ] Wow
it feels so natural to hear and this is
no disrespect to my southern friends we
have so many friends and viewers of the
show
from the South but it feels so natural
to hear hatred mail this particular one
interpreted with that accent yes this
voice actor is very very talented yeah
not only for the accent but also the the
way he was able to pronounce
multiculturalism well that's how it was
yeah I mean it's amazing to figure out
what how these things should be
pronounced turn hatred mail into
something good for the show you can use
the coupon code hey tree at 40 and get a
40% discount off of membership at david
pakman.com slash membership that is
spelled h8
cRIO t40 all lowercase no spaces